pigging see here it is in the future you
and I have been enemies for years there
have been others of course it's gone
zoom DeVoe but none of them hurt you
likes avatar Cajun truly broke you had
to be honest was right a little bit
jealous but now it's like I get to kill
her too if you excuse me I have my
execution to attend
[Music]
[Applause]
you
hey youtubers is Charlie so you guys
asked me about the future villains on
the flash Deveaux and Caitlin snow so
I'm going to explain what's going on and
what it is they're teasing here if
you're new to the channel I do Marvel
and DC every week be sure to subscribe
to get everything there's a giveaway
happening I'll explain at the end of the
video but as you can tell from these
clips they're basically telling you who
are going to be villains in the future
now that could be season for now caitlin
snow is a little more imminent but the
thinker is a bit of a hat tip to
something really big that's going to be
happening on the flash he's sort of a
mastermind type villain who controls
other villains and consolidates powers
the Caitlin snow stuff is a little more
imminent because she is on the warpath
right now and we only got a teaser for
DeVoe so a lot of you were like who's
DeVoe what's going on so this is where
it gets really cool his real name is
Clifford DeVoe he's called the thinker
he goes all the way back to the Jay
Garrick era so he's a Jay Garrick Barry
Allen Wally West crossover villain
meaning that they can have a really epic
episode with all three of those
characters whenever they decide to
introduce them but the cool thing about
him is that he starts out as a normal
person back during the Jay Garrick era
he debuted back in the all flash title
number 12 in 1943
so he goes way back he was a really bad
attorney who just came to the conclusion
that all of Gotham's villains were bad
because they lacked organization in the
mental capacity so he took on that task
he made a thinking cap that allowed him
to project himself psychically in
control of the people the way that
Gorilla Grodd controls people
psychically he became a member of the in
Justice Society and here's a really cool
Easter Egg so if you remember during the
flash season 2 when they introduced the
Jay Garrick character secretly it wasn't
Jay Garrick but they did the flash of
two worlds they made this special comic
book cover for the episode it was flash
issue number 123
so during volume 2 of the flash during
the Wally West era in 1997 volume 2
number 123 they did a story called the
flash of Two Cities where Barry and
Wally found out that devote in a couple
other flash villains had stolen Keystone
City and hid it in stasis for a number
of years allowing them to stay young so
the devote could come back into the
modern continuity and be a villain for
the new flash for Wally West so that was
just a clever way to refresh an old
character and bring him from
Golden Age all the way up to the modern
age so you have Silver Age Barry Allen
this in-between period where they tried
to update villains but every once in a
while they pull someone from way back in
the Golden Age this was just a Mark Waid
story attempt to explain why we hadn't
seen Clifford devote to thinker in so
long so he comes back he's still young
and then they go on to be a couple of
the versions of the character but
because abracadabra named devote
specifically they're going to start with
the first version of the character when
they bring him on so like I said he's a
mastermind type character who organizes
other villains he perpetrates crimes by
using other people to help him out so
it's sort of like a Captain Cold rogue
situation but you have to imagine that
they try to do different characters each
year so when they bring the rogues back
it'll be really cool we'll have killer
Frost who will arguably be a villain
i'll explain her in a second she's kind
of a separate thing from Devo Devo is
just going to be the stand-in potential
big bad but he's not confirmed as the
big villain of season four or anything
like that it's just that abracadabra was
saying that he was on the level of other
flash villains such as eobard thawne in
zoom and sabotage and those were the big
bags of their respective seasons season
1 season 2 season 3 so he's definitely
making it sound like DeVoe will be one
of the big bads in the future maybe
season four could be season five but
usually when they tease stuff like this
they pay it off relatively soon so it
sounds like a season four thing but the
other big part of this clip killer frost
so very clearly the fallout from Barry's
flashpoint mistake is going to haunt him
for the rest of the season and it seems
like into season four because what kind
of a middle finger would it be for them
to show the consequences of Barry's
actions he is by eel barred Dawn's
definition the villain of this season
because he selfishly caused flashpoint
his friends suffer because of that
mistake so if they want to stick the
landing they need to show us that
they're not going to magically fix
everything at the end of the season like
oh it never happened because I went back
in time so because this twist is
happening so deep in the season it seems
like they're developing her as a
potential mid-level villain because
she's a big character with a personal
connection to the heroes so think about
how heartbreaking is going to be for
them in season 4 in daniel pan
maker the actress think they just
finished filming the finale on arrow
they might be done on the flash but she
said that as recently as last week she
had her very last costume fitting for
the season and she already has all of
her Caitlin snow costumes so she's
probably talking about it you know drum
roll wait for it a killer frost costume
in the vein of what she was wearing when
she was fighting Cisco when he vibed her
potential future so anything could
change between now and the end of the
season there are a couple things they'll
probably change iris West will still be
alive in season 4 so they'll have to do
something to fix that but the whole idea
is that the hero only achieves victory
at great cost in Caitlin seems like one
of the big costs that he's going to have
to pay for his mistakes so while this is
science fiction they could be any number
of twists in the future they could
reverse what's happened to her she could
go back to being Caitlin any time they
want to we have the multiverse there's
so many different ways to explain it
logically it just seems like they're
giving danielle Panabaker the actress a
really interesting challenge for the
next season in that she will be more
killer frost than she is Caitlin snow
for however many episodes beyond the
devotees and the killer frost tease at
the end of this recent episode they
haven't said anything about season 4
other than the big bad will not be a
speedster so they're just leaning more
in that Deveaux direction but we'll
learn more as we get closer to the
finale and they did say that Jay Garrick
would probably show up again relatively
close to the finale it's not in the
finale they have to address him being
stuck in the Speed Force at some point
because the Sabbat are was in there now
he's not because Jay Garrick's taken his
place at some point somebody has to
replace him in there hopefully it's not
Barry before season 4 hopefully he
doesn't take one for the team because
the show is called the flash it wouldn't
be a whole out without Barry Allen but
they do like to end seasons on big WTF
cliffhangers speaking of which
Supergirl just confirmed that Superman
is coming back for her finale - they
didn't say what he's going to be doing
but it sounds like they're inching
towards Brainiac we have Lex Luthor's
warframe Leena Luthor is confirmed as a
season 3 Supergirl regular meaning she's
going to be in most of the episodes much
bigger character than she wasn't season
2 but that is where we're at in terms of
flash season 4 stuff there are five more
episodes in the season so there's plenty
more time for them to tease new villains
and there's
future scientists played by this actress
here that we haven't even met yet so
there's still a bunch of new stuff
they're going to introduce that will
probably throw into season four usually
the stuff that they T up at the very end
of the season is stuff that carries over
so let me know what what are you really
excited about in season four I know
everybody's happy that there won't be
another speedster villain even though
reverse-flash is supposed to come back
there'll be other speedsters on the show
that berry will fight other antagonists
it's just that they won't be the main
villain of the season so they've all
your requests for flash videos in the
comments below we selves a couple weeks
before it comes back but this is kind of
like Star Wars week because Star Wars
Celebration is happening so I'll be
posting panel videos there'll be a
trailer video later this week there'll
be all kinds of stuff happening for the
next couple days but there's a new round
of the flash ring giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video congratulations
to the winner from my last video
Kevin LaRoche please private message me
so I can get your contact details in
while you wait for that next video you
can click here to learn all about
Deathstroke coming back to arrow I know
there's a lot of confusion about that
but the producers did confirm there
would be Deathstroke and you can click
here for brand new Star Wars thank you
so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys in the next video